when things go wrong they sometimes will  when the road you're trudging seems all  uphill when funds are low and the debts  are high and you want to smile but you  have to say when care is pressing you  down a bit rest if you must but don't  you quit life is queer with his twists  and turns as everyone of us sometimes  learns and many of failure turns about  when he might have won had he stuck it  out don't give up though the pace seems  slow you may succeed with another blow  success is failure turned inside out the  silver tint of the clouds of doubt and  you never can tell how close you are it  may be near when it seems so far so  stick to the fight when your heart is  hit it's when things seem worst but you  must not quit  you